Howard we have to hurry up because we
need to talk to George Takei is she
right on there now yeah we can talk to
him on the satellite oh he's on the
satellite hello hello
ah George my old friend oh how are you
Howard can you hear me okay I hear you
fine I've been listening in on you uh
all this time you know I gotta ask you a
question first I know because you wrote
a book
do you uh now you enunciate in real life
I mean you are the most enunciating guy
I know you wouldn't have to see like you
say Howard Howard yeah you are really
into enunciating everywhere did you do
that yeah but on Star Trek you never did
that no because I'm acting oh I'm I'm
not being me I'm being Sulu
it's unusual I mean you catch me by
surprise when I hear you in real life
because I'm shocked I thought you were
Beyond surprise haven't you lived and
been exposed to everything that's
possible yeah well I'm the one that's
shocking you am I hey George you know
what I love about your new book yes what
I look I love the fact that you take on
this William Shatner I love it finally I
mean it took you long enough you know I
recognize him for what he is I mean he's
a very talented actor but the thing is
you have to look at the whole man so
when you sit there and talk about uh
Shatner the reason you hate him is
because he was ungracious he was not
gracious as an actor he didn't allow you
to be in certain scenes he was uh he
wouldn't talk to you at certain points
on the set right he he's got this charm
that he thinks is going to cover up all
the other things that he does to people
oh so he's nice to you while he's
cutting your throat he's got that smile
and that wit and you know at first uh
you know everybody gets uh taken in by
that but over the years you said you
know you see the see through the man and
frankly I see him as a rather sad kind
of guy you know who never really outgrew
that uh beginning actors syndrome right
cutting lines and doing everything he
can to bring attention to himself you
know we we mature as actors after a
while and you we we learn I love how you
say mature
mature what do you think will happen if
you run into Shatner at a party one of
those fancy Hollywood parties let's say
you just happened who would you know if
there are a lot of other people in
particular to press around he would come
up to me and embrace me and say
Georgie how have you been oh really oh
you look wonderful hey anyway George yes
I'm glad that you came on our show today
to trash William shot Farewell My friend
thank you very much the great George
Takei live long and prosper